children crying all the time and they
calling please help us
and
sometimes we cannot do anything because
russian occupiers
lower that territory from his home in
kiev lights switched off for safety you
will
you can hear alarm syringe
and
we have to go to the basement ukraine's
former ombudsman for children michola
coleba describes harrowing rescues from
hundreds of orphanages across the
country it's horrible because
more and more children every day dying
because russian shells putin's shells
everywhere kuleba and his team are
desperately trying to save thousands of
children in cities under attack they
feel abandoned and betrayed
and
don't feel protected and safe
they don't feel that they're loved the
derzanovska family is from ukraine now
living in barrie ontario four of the
children were adopted from orphanages
including gloria
sent to sensitive sensitive too
traumatized to speak about what's
happening back home with siblings still
there their mother who has worked to
reform the child protection system in
ukraine sees a crisis unfolding i come
to just contact all these people how to
make it uh
faster to
to take this children to most
safety places like western union or uh
close countries to romania
poland moldova etc ontario's former
child advocate says this is an
opportunity for this province to help to
flow some funds directly to those
organizations on the ground who need it
immediately despite the risks kuleba
says he plans to continue carrying out
missions to bring children in orphanages
to safety it's because we love our
children and we love our country karen
lieberman global news